let's try to construct a situation where
i participate in the the new treasury
public private program and i get all of
the upside i would have gotten in a
traditional just straight-up investment
of these toxic securities but then i'm
able to offload some of the downside and
so just as a review
what the program entails is
that if i want to make an investment in
something
let's say i want to make
a
100 or 100 percent investment doesn't
matter either way
that's a hundred
the fed is going to give us a loan for
85 percent of it
85 of it
and then the remainder the equity is
going to be split half between or 50 50
between myself and the treasury
treasury and then this is the private
investor
so what happens here and we talked a lot
about it in the last couple of videos is
that the upside right if this thing is
worth more than 100 is split between the
treasury and the private investor and
then the downside is split between the
private investor and the treasury until
the asset becomes less worth less than
85 percent of its original value and
then the fed takes the hit right because
this loan won't be worth anything and
all the sloan can go after is this asset
it's a non-recourse loan it can't
the the fed can't say oh this thing is
only worth 84. private investor and
treasury you guys owe me a dollar the
tread the fed is just left with this
asset that might be worth something less
than that but how could we use this
program to get the same upside we would
have otherwise gotten if we had just
bought the toxic security outright so
let's say that the toxic security in a
in kind of before this
program world that that geithner has
come up with let's say that i'm willing
to pay
30 for security and obviously if the
security is worth 40 i'll make ten
dollars if it's worth fifty dollars i'll
make twenty dollars and so forth and so
on that's obvious now what i can do is
instead of just with this plan i mean
before i would have to take my thirty
dollars that i have in the bank and use
it to buy some asset if one of these
banks were willing to sell it for to me
but what i can do now is
i could say well let me just take 15
percent of this so it's 15 percent of 30
dollars it's uh 4.50 and use that to
invest in this program and essentially
get the same upside as i would if i
invested the whole 30 and then put the
other cash the rest of the cash away
essentially safe so that it's you know
my my worst case is that i just lose
what i invest so let's do that and we'll
see that the numbers do all work out so
instead of just doing 30
all for the investment i'm going to set
aside 15 percent
so i'm going to put 450
to participate in the plan
and then i'm going to set aside what's
left 25 50 in cash
cash
right and using this 450 in the plan
i'll show you that i'll get all of the
upside that i got if i had originally
had to use all 30 dollars by myself and
obviously my downside is limited my
downside is limited to the 450 because
i'm still going to have the 25.50 in
cash on the side so how's this going to
work i'm going to put in
i'm going to put in 450
that's from
me the private investor
the
treasury is going to match my investment
that's the treasury
now i have nine dollars of equity
and this is going to be 15 of the total
equity so
the the debt that the fed will lend me
is going to be 51
and i did the math before i did the
video but you could work it out yourself
51 dollar
loan
from the fed
right and so what's our total uh capital
that we've raised now so if you add 51
plus 9 we have 60
dollars right let me do this in a
different color
we now have sixty dollars
and we could use that sixty dollars if
if someone was willing to sell me one i
guess we could say one of the units or
one of the securities for thirty dollars
now with sixty dollars we can buy two of
the units
so we could buy two of them
for thirty dollars
and why why did i end up making the math
work so we get two securities because we
split the upside right
we split the upside with the treasury so
in order to set up a situation where i
get all of the upside that i would have
gotten with a thirty dollar security
with a thirty security i essentially
have to set up a configuration where we
buy twice as many securities i buy twice
as many securities and then i split the
upside 50 50 with the treasury then i'm
just going to get the upside you could
almost view it on one security and let's
let's see let's see how the math works
out now
let's do a bunch of scenarios
so
in the world
where maybe i should do a table
yeah let's say that the eventual value
of the security let's say it's worth
zero i'm gonna make a bunch of numbers
up let's see zero
um
i don't know let's say it's 10
50.
60.
that's good enough so let's say that
these securities end up being worth
nothing
how much am i left with what's the total
value of my total investment right well
if these are worth nothing then i get
wiped out we all get wiped out here in
fact everyone gets wiped out here so how
much should i lose
well my 450 is gone this goes to zero
but what is my total investment went
left with i still have only i still have
my 2550 that i put out put it to the
side right
so i still have my 25.50 in cash
50.
if each of these securities are worth 10
dollars
right this is the eventual value of each
of the units so if these each of these
are worth ten dollars then the whole
asset side of this balance sheet is
worth twenty dollars and once again the
fed is going to take a thirty one dollar
hit and these two guys are wiped out so
my investment is worth nothing but i
still have that money i set aside in the
bank 25.50
see in this if both of the if these
securities are worth twenty dollars then
this whole asset side is worth forty
dollars because there's going to be two
of them the fed is still taking a hit
doesn't get all his money back and these
two guys still get wiped out my 450 is
gone i still have my money in my bank 25
50.
if this security is worth 30 dollars
which is essentially the price that
we're paying for it then this is what
the balance is going to look like so my
equity is worth 450 but at 450
plus the money that i had set aside
right i have 450 plus let me plus this
25.50 that i'd put aside in in the bank
because that's i didn't have to invest
that i just had to invest the 450
initially so i have my 450 here plus
25.50 so the value of all of my
investments is thirty dollars
what happens if each of these units are
worth forty dollars if each of these are
worth forty dollars then we have eighty
dollars on the left hand side of the
balance sheet so let me draw that really
small here so then we'll have
two units
that are worth forty that's eighty
dollars
we owe
51 dollars to the fed
right so we're going to have 29
to split between
the treasury and ourselves
29 so we're each going to
29 divided by 2 is 14.50
14.50 we're each going to have
we're each going to uh split that 29 so
my equity is now worth 1450. so my total
investment is going to be the cash that
i put aside so that's let's say 29 25.50
plus the value of my equity investment
now so that's plus 14.50
and so it's worth
40. i think you see the pattern here and
all of these kind of downside scenarios
the most i lost was 450 and now in all
of these upside scenarios we're going to
see that i get the value of the actual
security let's do it for 50 but i think
you know how the math is going to work
out if each of these end up being worth
fifty dollars then this whole
left hand side is a hundred dollars
we owe the fed fifty one so this is
going to be forty nine dollars
and so if you split that it's 20
it's 24.50
our the money we set aside in the bank
is 25.50
and so this is worth fifty dollars
and likewise if these are each worth
sixty dollars this is going to turn out
to be 60.
so what you see here and i'm going to
draw a payoff diagram
if we
let me draw a line here
and this is
let's see if i can do this right
so if this is the
eventual value
of the asset right when we pay something
in the market you know we're hoping
we're buying it for less than its real
value but we really don't know 100 what
the eventual value is but this x-axis is
the eventual value
the eventual
value
so it could be 10
60 and so on and so forth so what if
depending on this eventual value what is
the value of my investment
so we figured out if it's 0 10 20
all the way really up to
so at what point
it has to be
so 0 10 20 the my the value of my
investment is going to be i didn't have
to draw this stuff down here
let's see let's say that this is 2450
2450. so in all of these scenarios
in all of these scenarios
whoops trying to draw a line
so 20
and then
at 25
right if
if this thing is worth i mean we could
figure out the break even right if this
if these assets are worth anything more
combined than 51 dollars then we start
to have value to the equity so what's
that value that's this divided by 2 is
twenty five fifty so after twenty five
fifty
some value starts going to the equity
and we know at thirty dollars let me
draw those points actually
i'll do it in a different color when
we're in the money
so thirty dollars
the value of our security is
thirty
at forty dollars the value of our
security is
forty and so on and so forth and let me
draw a line now
so our
payoff
no that's not what i want to do let's
draw a regular line
our payoff would look something like
this
right this is a good visualization for
what the government is giving us and
i'll show you that what they're giving
us is essentially insurance or put
option for free and then we can talk in
the next video about how we can value it
and then we have a real sense of what
the government is handing over to the
investor now you might say that it's
handing to the investor but if because
of this the investor overpays for the
asset that subsidy is really going to
the person selling the asset we'll talk
about that a little bit more in the next
video but let me just finish this up a
little bit
so we said that this the point at which
we start making money right
the point well no uh let me see the
point which we start making money is
here because this is what we paid for
the security
right we're paying 30 for the security
so
these are all the scenarios where we
start making money we're where the the
security is worth more than that but the
equity is actually worth something above
24.50 above 24.50 or what is this yeah
above 25.50 but we're still taking a
slight loss but the cool thing is if we
are the private investor here is even if
the thing is worth very little we don't
take
that much of a loss here and this is
much better what would the what would
the payoff diagram have looked like if
we were just a straight-up investor let
me just draw that in a different color
well then it would look something like
this we would have had the same upside
let me get the line tool
we would have had the same upside
but our downside
would have gone all the way to zero if
the acid was at zero we would have been
worth well these lines are supposed to
be on top of each other
but i think you get the idea that the
government is saving us from these
losses right here
so i'm all out of oh i think you can't
see it i'm off the screen the
government's saving us from these losses
right there
and so i'm out of time in this video in
the next video i'm going to actually
analyze what that subsidy or what that
insurance or that option that the
government is giving us what it might be
worth and then we could think about
whether now people are willing to
actually overpay for these things see in
the next video